c'est une nouvelle étape pour le câble à
saint quentin en yvelines
l'agglomération a signé ce matin la
vente de son réseau à l'opérateur sfr
une session à 15 millions d'euros le
groupe des agglomérations les faits le
chou en 2005 de devenir propriétaire du
réseau qui était exploitée par
numericable
entre-temps numericable a été racheté
par sfr et donc nous avons souhaité nous
en 2014 est tout simplement nous
recentrer sur les activités d'une
collectivité et le côté très technique
de l'exploitation d'un réseau table et
nous avons souhaité aujourd'hui nous ont
séparés 50 % de cette somme ira
directement dans les caisses de
l'agglomération et les autres 50% seront
directement investis sur les réseaux aux
bénéfices et bien sûr des saint
quentinois nerfs l'accord conclu prévoit
aussi la modernisation du réseau d'ici
la fin de l'année 2017 soixante mille
logements supplémentaires de
l'agglomération auront accès au très
haut débit à un gigabit par seconde
comment ça se passe techniquement
parlant aujourd'hui on va déployer de la
fibre c'est à dire qu'on va remplacer le
câble existantes dans la rue par de la
fibre optique qu'on va amener au pied
des bâtiments
en revanche on va garder
l'infrastructure existante dans l'est
notamment dans les immeubles pour éviter
pour démonter pour éviter de déployer la
fibre en local
dirt percer les murs chez dédé dans les
logements des habitants cette commune de
l'agglomération seront concernés les
travaux ont débuté sur montigny le
bretonneux dans cette commune 1720
logements et locaux professionnels sont
dès aujourd'hui éligibles au très haut
débit